let's bring it to breaking news now out
of nigeria where a 21-storey building
has collapsed in lagos it's believed 50
people are trapped
officials have been trying to demolish
or retrofit unsafe buildings in lagos
which is africa's second most populous
city
more than 80 buildings have been
demolished so far this year
let's cross now to ahmad idris he's
following the story from neighbouring
chad ahmed what more can you tell us
about this building collapse
well basically it happened this
afternoon hala and what we know so far
is that two people have been pulled out
alive first on the scenes were
ambulances and emergency workers but
there was
nothing much they could do they tried to
dig through the rubble with their bare
hands until uh this hour
15 18 minutes ago when heavy duty
machinery started coming into that area
of lagos which is a high brow
residential and commercial estate in
lagos city and then the work started in
earnest looking at the rubble the
mountain of rubble they in fact needed
much more bigger uh heavy-duty equipment
to move the rubble in order to access
the people who have been trapped inside
that building now it's not clear exactly
how many people have been trapped and
emergency workers are really silent
about the number of people who've been
killed because of this disaster lagos is
no stranger to this disaster respecting
the construction code has always been a
difficult situation in lagos enforcement
despite enforcement such contraventions
continue not only in lagos but across
cities in nigeria people bribe officials
to look the other way while they uh
they go scheming things and making
construction uh or constructing poorly
built uh structures in lagos eventually
these structures collapsed and killed a
lot of people every year we register
such incidences but again in
the area where this incident occurred
it's expected that officials are
watching closely because this is a high
brow area and people expect officials
in that area will be watching exactly
and constantly how these construction
works continue uh it's not clear whether
it's the fault of construction
construction workers or it's because of
climate change lagos has been sinking uh
over the past few years because of
climate change there's been a lot of
flooding in that area but it's too early
to say exactly what caused that incident
harlow okay ahmad idris there live for
us there from chad ahmed for now thank
you very much indeed